[Music]
so
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
it's election day
you're in a state where you can vote you
should be voting today
exercise your right to democracy
engage in the ballot
register
people to vote
go to the polls
make your voice heard
that's what you should be doing
there's great news um
thanks brandon
joe biden smokes terrorist as you saw
the the um the title to the show today
is president biden smokes terrorist
they got the number two the current
leader of al qaeda
now
it is it is amusing to watch republicans
twist themselves into pretzels to figure
out a way to explain why they hate
veterans
over the last few days about the pact
act over the weekend to try to figure
out oh what are we gonna lie about how
are we gonna how are we gonna make the
democrats the enemy
when we hate veterans because we won't
vote for them to have the health care
that they're supposed to get
and john tester uh gave an interview
last night
senator john tester and said it
perfectly
keeping these veterans from health care
is a dereliction of duty
to these senators and for them to put
this off and put this off and put this
off
to vote for this bill that they've
already voted for there was just a
technicality to revoke for the bill
and to get all but hurt that the
democrats
have started to have legislation success
in the senate
damn is breaking with joe manchin
and some areas to have success
with the inflation reduction act they
don't like that
speaking of that
speaking of successes because there's a
lot of success
for our democracy here
you notice the uh i i think it was
lauren bobert bobo the clown she tweeted
the other day that the inflation
reduction act is the bill back better
bill
or something like that something along
those lines
and i was like yes so
okay
great so so they named it something
different
so that people could vote for it this is
again this goes back to the messaging i
said this all last year when they had
the bill back better act such a stupid
[ __ ] name stupid [ __ ] name stop
naming these bills stupidly
name them something that
these these morons on capitol hill will
vote for
because that's all they give a [ __ ]
about and at the end of the day
that's why ted cruz is fist bumping
when he kills the packed act because it
didn't say
the veteran's health care bill he
wouldn't be fist bumping
if it had not changed its name to the
pact act
what's the pac deck what the hell is
that
i don't even know what that is the
democrats tried to change
from discretionary to mandatory no they
didn't you [ __ ] liars
john stewart goes on newsmax again this
morning to call them [ __ ] liars but
they're not just lying about the packed
act and veterans they're lying about
afghanistan they're lying about what the
the al qaeda leader that joe biden just
killed
with a drone strike
the reports are there are no civilian
casualties at this point and no one from
his family was injured
it was just him somehow this [ __ ]
this missile that they used has like
swords on it or some [ __ ] i don't know
i don't know sounds like some kind of
[ __ ]
james bond movie type [ __ ]
but it's got it's got blades on it have
you seen this
this missile they use to kill
i think it's al raziri i think it's his
name
he's the number two he was he was
he was bin laden's lieutenant
and as you remember last summer when joe
biden
finally did what but the three
presidents before him should have done
which is leave afghanistan
and we wouldn't have the casualties that
we have on the list today if they would
have done that
but joe biden made the decision that yes
it's tough and we're going to leave and
not only that he had the most successful
operation to get people out of that
country in the quickest amount of time
ever
in the history of ever ever
it was a successful exit yes there are
some soldiers that lost their lives
but that's what war is
that's why we had to leave afghanistan
it's ridiculous that we expect american
soldiers to go lose their lives
when in a country
that acts like they're wanting to
progress they're not
and they're harboring the number two
al-qaeda leader which he's now the
number one he was
osama bin laden's lieutenant
he is no more
now the problem is with these groups
just like with our domestic terrorist
group
maga our domestic terrorism group maga
just because you get rid of one leader
doesn't mean the next one's not gonna
fill the void
that's what terrorist groups do
that's why you have to keep going after
them that's why biden
with the opportunity
took his chance
and he was successful
making sure there was no american
casualties
at as the reporting goes right now there
was no civilian casualties in
afghanistan in kabul
none of his family was injured or hurt
the terrorist that is
and of course they want to act like this
is some kind of
not success for joe biden in the
administration in our country
tucker carlson wants to blabber on about
how it was a botched to leave from
afghanistan what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you [ __ ] rube
we left afghanistan last summer the
american people didn't even know we were
still in afghanistan you [ __ ]
that's right it had been such a long war
it had been such
such a [ __ ] habit that the american
people
didn't even realize we were still in
afghanistan until biden left
we got so complacent
derelict in our duty as citizens frankly
to just leave it up to the volunteers
the volunteers in the military to take
care of that problem over there
and that's why joe biden left
and that's why he should have left
that's why trump should have left that's
why obama that's why bush should have
left
we should have not left our soldiers and
our veterans to slaughter
and then after all that service
after all that service that they gave
our country voluntarily going over to
afghanistan and iraq
riddled with cancer because of burn pits
and other toxins
the republicans that are blaming joe
biden and acting like
getting rid of the lieutenant of osama
bin laden is a bad thing here
the same [ __ ] are voting
against and holding up
health care for those veterans
think about it
so biden smokes a terrorist in
afghanistan
maybe he should start rolling up and
smoking terrorists here at home
just walking all over them politically
this is ridiculous
and we can help him do this with
democracy maga is a domestic terrorist
group
i want to show you a videotape speaking
of domestic terrorist being sentenced to
federal prison
the daughter of the first man
who was convicted with a jury and
sentenced by a judge got seven and a
half years
for his participation in the january six
insurrection
seven and a half years
his daughter stood outside the federal
courthouse and said
well if my dad's gonna get seven and a
half years trump should get life in
prison if that's the case
listen folks this
idea that somehow
these maga republicans these
trumpledites this trumpism is popular in
this country is just a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's fraud
the biggest fraud that donald trump has
ever wrought on our country is that the
majority of people support him
bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
i do not believe that for one goddamn
second
not one [ __ ] second do i believe that
as an american president has success
in taking down the number two
now the leader of al-qaeda
an actual terrorist group
who threatened and murdered thousands
who killed thousands of our soldiers of
our countrymen and women
they're like oh buttons so weak
buttons weak america's we they [ __ ]
hate america
okay they [ __ ] hate america they
can't say anything good about america
anymore
and these are supposed to be our [ __ ]
patriots here get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
not one good thing that can they say
about our country not [ __ ] one
and sometimes it's tough yeah because
man we got some [ __ ] boxes here it is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show has been for a while
because of these [ __ ] fascists here
that's why no one wants to come here
that's why no one wants to be here
that's why no one wants to [ __ ]
participate in a democracy because a
bunch of fascists have control of it but
that's the reason why to engage and
today is election day
and you can make your voice heard you
can show these [ __ ] idiots that this
this nonsense about trump has half the
country under his wing
that the republicans somehow
are are taking back the house and gonna
take the senate and they're gonna win in
2024 and they're gonna win all these
races and now's the time for you to go
show them to go [ __ ] themselves
today's the day you can do it
so go to the ballot mark your ballot
help other folks to the polls if you
know people who want to vote and they
can't get a ride
or they need help getting to the poll
help them out
you can do that you can give them a ride
to the poll
your friend your neighbor your mom your
sister your brother your cousin
let them vote let their voice be heard
too and register
there's nothing wrong with registering
people to vote on a day like today
especially
if they're not aware that there was a
primary in their state
and they're not
sometimes there's same-day registration
sometimes there's not but it doesn't
mean you can't register people for the
general
because we're gonna need the votes we're
gonna need the votes
because we just can't beat these
fascists
in these elections we can't just beat
these fascists in these elections we
have to absolutely pile them
mound them with mountains of votes
to show the country and to show the
world and to show ourselves
that this manga [ __ ] this america first
nazism this white christian nationalism
it is just a small [ __ ] percentage of
people here in this country that believe
that [ __ ] garbage that want fascism
that want marjorie taylor green and
donald trump to run get the [ __ ] out of
here with that nonsense you you see this
they're standing on the balcony
at a goddamn saudi golf tournament
were these [ __ ] did you hear
this
tiger woods was offered like 700 million
dollars and he told him to go [ __ ]
himself
oh greg norman on tucker carlson whining
oh why why do men get oh man the men are
ridiculed because we took blood money
yeah
yeah you're being ridiculed to take
blood money they were selling the
tickets of this [ __ ] for a
dollar on stubhub
just to cap it off the whole reason why
the saudis spent so much [ __ ]
money on this thing
is so that white americans
men would stand with a trophy that
looked like the [ __ ] twin towers that
had fell in new york city in 9 11.
that's the whole goddamn reason
i believe it i think that's the whole
[ __ ] reason why they did this whole
thing is to troll
they spent all that money convinced all
these dumb [ __ ] to take this
blood money so they had a picture
of a bunch of white dudes golfers in
america
taking the trophy that looks like the
towers that fell on 911.
can't convince me otherwise i'll believe
what the [ __ ] i want to believe they get
to
they get to believe anything they want
i'm going to show you the picture
i'm going to show you the picture of the
stupid [ __ ] trophy it's gross it's
[ __ ] gross they did it on purpose
greg norman bitching oh
why did they ridicule the men
maybe you and tucker carlson greg norman
should go tan your balls together
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
but marjorie taylor green and donald
trump stand on the balcony oh we're
gonna run we're gonna run no you're not
no you're not
and today is election day so make your
voice heard
again even if you can't vote in your
state even if you can't vote in your
state today is election day people are
going to be thinking about this now is
the time to engage with people even if
your state doesn't have an election you
can engage with people and have
conversations about the election about
the results tomorrow today
get them registered to vote if they're
not registered to vote
start talking to them about the issues
and the only issue that matters is
staving off fascism
we saw it yesterday
well speaking of the [ __ ]
at betminster holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy
the former guy
goes on his fraud social yesterday and
says i'm going to announce sometime
today who i'm going to endorse in the
missouri senate race
that's an important race and the reason
why it now the reason why donald trump
the former guy the cheeto dust mobster
himself grandpa poopypants hadn't
actually endorsed yet it's because that
actual race
that race didn't look
like it was going to be important
it looked like well no matter which
republican wins they're going to win the
state of missouri
well the problem is since they
overturned roe v wade
there has been a huge
a huge surge of registering to vote here
in the state of missouri
huge
which is terrifying the absolute [ __ ]
out of them terrifying the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of them here in missouri and the
reason why is because they know they're
not registering because roe was
overturned and people are excited about
it
they're not people don't want their
contraception taken away they don't want
their right to go get a [ __ ] medical
procedure to save their life they do not
want their wife
their lover
their loved one their daughter
their niece
their mother
not to have the ability
to make the decisions about her body
they're [ __ ] pissed off about it
they're [ __ ] pissed off about it
and republicans are terrified that they
made a big mistake here
because it was a shoo-in that one of
these republicans rather be that [ __ ]
disgraced piece of [ __ ] sexual
abuser eric greitens that's right i said
it
and [ __ ] accused and
and he had to leave his governorship for
duct taping a woman naked to his
treadmill in his basement
duct taped his hairdresser naked to a
treadmill in his basement took pictures
to blackmail her so she would perform
sexual acts on him
and that's not even the worst part of it
he stole money from a veteran's charity
and then he created a commercial talking
about how he's going to kill dissidents
of his party
don't believe me go look at the [ __ ]
evidence
i've showed it here
but eric greitens was poised to possibly
win this primary the attorney general of
the state of missouri that [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
that's right eric schmidt is a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
that attorney general has spent our tax
dollars the taxpayers money
on lawsuit after lawsuit after lawsuit
school suing local school districts
for choosing what they chose to choose
during their policy for covenant safety
they shoot school districts over school
surveys
spent the taxpayers dollars
to sue school districts over surveys
that they that they gave parents
that had nothing to do with crt not a
goddamn thing
not a goddamn thing about race not a
goddamn thing about politics
schools do surveys all the time to get a
sense of where their parents are at
and where the district is at
especially when you're talking about
redistricting building new schools
switching what what the district looks
like
and eric schmidt sued those schools and
those schools had to spend their money
as well so not only did he spend the tax
dollars of the people of the state of
missouri then he spent the local tax
dollars
of the school district
he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] all all to
get his name in the news so he could run
on the taxpayers dollar that's what he's
done here in missouri
so donald trump endorses eric that's
literally what he says in this statement
i'm going to show it to you eric
he doesn't say if it's eric schmidt or
eric greitens now there's another eric
in the race no one gives a [ __ ] about
that guy
no one even knows who the [ __ ] he is
there's like a hundred of them in this
primary
but eric schmidt and eric greitens are
the two that are
polling the highest i mean you got the
the mccloskey guy you know the guy with
the gun him and his wife the two cairns
with the gun the one that the the the
governor mike parsons that [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] pardoned them from their [ __ ]
felony crimes here in the state of
missouri because they were [ __ ]
pointing guns with their fingers on the
trigger because peop black people were
walking on their sidewalk
you remember the pictures i don't have
the [ __ ] i may show them but that's
another guy that's running another
stupid idiot that's running
is vicki hartzler that [ __ ] idiot
vicky hartzler is nowhere to be found in
this race
she doesn't even pull but i don't i
don't think she pulls more than
mccloskey
and she's a sitting united states
congresswoman
and she ain't got the microphone to
to out trump these trumpers
but he goes out and he says
i'm going to
i'm going to endorse eric he doesn't say
the last name so yesterday on twitter
eric greitens and eric schmidt decide
they're gonna you know
they're gonna claim that trump endorsed
them
now why is all this important because
the senate the missouri senate race
doesn't seem that important it didn't
six months ago now i thought it was
going to be very important because i
think a democrat can win here in
missouri
especially now
if eric schmidt or eric greitens wins
trump says i picked the winner
and of course they're going to embrace
the trumpism
of course they're going to no matter
which one wins
the other factor that's in play for the
general election is john wood he was an
attorney with the january 6th select
committee
he's a republican now he's running on
the independent ticket here in missouri
now this is significant
and the reason why it's significant with
registration up
with with republican voters discouraged
about voting and voting machines
there's a chance with a third-party
candidate
to steal part of that republican vote
that are tired of trumpers
they're tired of trumpism
i would bet that eric schmidt probably
wins this primary the attorney general
of the state of missouri now it's it's
possible that that [ __ ] psychopath
eric greitens wins it is possible i i i
don't i don't think
with some of the with some of the press
that he's had lately
about how he's abused his wife and his
children in their in their custody case
that has come out
i don't know that he's going to um
you're going to be surprised though even
though he loses eric greitens the former
disgrace governor even though he loses
you're going to be like holy [ __ ] he got
that much of the vote
i'm sure it's going to be just gross and
vile of how many people are actually
going to vote for that piece of [ __ ]
and it just it just makes them a piece
of [ __ ]
but we need to know these things because
folks this election this midterm no
matter who the [ __ ] primary
candidates are no matter who ends up on
the ballot at the end of the day these
elections this 2022 midterm is the first
real national election
that we get to have we the people us get
to show our voice for january 6th you
realize that right
this is the very first national election
where we the people get to give our
opinion at the ballot about january 6th
and about trump trying to take our
[ __ ] democracy and about all these
[ __ ] trumpets all these manga
[ __ ]
running around soft cooing gonna say
they're gonna take over
overturning people's rights
wanting to ban contraception wanting to
[ __ ] wanting to marry children in
tennessee wanting to pass bills to make
sure that men don't have to pay child
support
in west virginia i'm not [ __ ] you
banning mac because of critical race
theory
going on going on and on and on and on
about all this america first nazi [ __ ]
this is the very first election we get
to say something
we the people we get to say something
so you have to engage in your democracy
you have to gauge in your ballot
so that your voice is heard it's not
just about marking the ballot
that's not the only thing in democracy
that's not just it
you have to yell you have to scream
or you can leave that up to me
but you can go talk to your family your
friends anyone around you start the
conversations
that donald trump is hedging his bet if
you're in missouri donald trump is
hedging his bet on which eric is going
to win and he doesn't care
donald trump does not care which eric
wins whether it's schmidt or greitens
now donald trump jr and kimberly
guilfoyle they give a [ __ ] because they
stuck their stake with greitens with
that psychopath
because they're psychopaths [ __ ]
lunatics
crazy ass [ __ ]
not surprising
but donald trump doesn't give a [ __ ]
which one wins because whichever eric
wins
in the primary they're going to embrace
trump that's all he gives a [ __ ] about
that's why yesterday when he [ __ ]
released that statement he's not really
hedging his bet
he just knows either one of them are
gonna [ __ ] get their cheeto dust knee
pads on
and they're going to worship at the
altar of trump
that's why he didn't come to the state
because he couldn't tell which one was
going to win and he doesn't want to pick
a loser
so he picked the winner yesterday
and because of that he's gonna say i
mean as soon as soon as it's announced
which one of these eric's wins this
primary he's gonna say see i i made him
win
literally he's gonna lie he's gonna
gaslight the [ __ ] out of his supporters
don't doubt it
and whoever eric wins they're gonna be
like yeah trump pulled me over the line
i couldn't have done it without
president trump blah blah blah yeah
smackity
but the key here the key here is this
election is important for your voice
rather it's in missouri wyoming florida
wherever these primaries are
your voice can be heard today
and in this midterm
this is our way of sending the message
no
enough of this nonsense enough of this
[ __ ]
this is the very first national election
since january 6.
this is it
and this is the one where you can slam
dunk this home
because before january 6 8 million more
people voted
against trump than voted for him
that's right i don't believe 81 million
people voted
for joe biden
there's a lot of those people that voted
against trumpism
and fascism and america first
nazism white christian nationalism
they're sick of the [ __ ] they're
sick of it they're sick of this stuff
they're sick of these vile indecent
inhumane cowards
just these pieces of [ __ ] republican
garbage
they're sick of it
boy we have a lot to cover we have a lot
of video to get to i mean i got a ton of
[ __ ] that we're gonna do surfing the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends i'm
glad you're joining us here every today
but every single weekday as you do
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simon casting from the
midas touch facebook page don't forget
to follow us here on youtube
click the subscribe button you don't
want to miss a thing
tomorrow we're going to do something a
little different normally we put out the
uh the bonehead of the week poll on
thursday but we'll be putting it out
tomorrow so go follow us on youtube as
well at the tony michael's pod
you don't want to miss the poll of
bonehead of the week
and also download every single episode
on apple spotify and google go over to
apple and spotify if you listen to the
podcast if you're listening to it give
us a good review we've had some trolls
trying to give us bad reviews oh those
manga trolls they get really upset at me
because of the [ __ ] i say they get
really mad at me they're really upset
these are far right wingers
these let's go brandon nazis they hate
when i say that stuff so they go over
there and they they type in stuff and
they give us a bad review so go give us
a good review if you want to but you
should go give us a good review over on
any directory that you're on apple
spotify google
stick around through the break when we
come back
we'll go through the [ __ ] list roundup
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends we're gonna surf it up stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacist the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babel mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us as you do every
single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
all those facebookers over there
thank you for joining us
it's election day as i said it's
election day
but we're gonna go through the tweety
tweets and the journey trends here the
[ __ ] list roundup
but again i want to implore you i want
to i want to stress how important it is
that you go make your voice heard
because you might you might think well
tony in a primary is it really that
important yes it is it is that important
to send the message to these fascists
can you imagine
if there is a huge turnout for primaries
and a lot of people in some states where
there isn't an open election you have to
pull your ballot and you you you
actually pull the ballot under your
registration
like missouri you can it's an open
primary
i mean you can pull a ballot from either
party but some states don't have open
primaries you have to vote on your
registration
so when you go they hand you the ballot
you voted for can you imagine
how scared they'll be if the if the
turnout for the primary is high
that's important so go
vote go exercise democracy do the thing
that you're supposed to do which is
democracy
do that thing it'll send a message
that is clear
we got him on the run folks we got him
on the run we just have to close strong
here
they're making all the mistakes
and all all the the unforced errors that
we could possibly ask for
and we can politicize the [ __ ] out of
that
why not they're politicizing the hell
out of changes that aren't made lies
about the pact act
we don't have to politicize the veterans
but we definitely can politicize that
they're lying pieces of garbage
and why would you want someone who lies
why would you want someone who lies to
the american people
about what a bill says
and they stall
the delivery of medical treatment
to veterans who are dying
because of the service to their country
who the [ __ ] wants them in charge of
anything the economy gas prices
inflation you want those stupid [ __ ] in
charge that are gonna lie to you
about changes that didn't happen in a
bill because they got caught hating
veterans
that's who you want in charge get the
[ __ ] out of here we're not doing that
[ __ ] not here in this country no a bunch
of traders running our government in
control of our economy in control of our
gas prices in control of our student
loans in control of our department of
education in control of youth and
health and human services and control of
the environmental protection agency you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me you want these [ __ ]
fascists
in charge of that even to have oversight
in congress of these things what the
[ __ ]
they can't even stop themselves from
lying because they got caught hating
veterans
making sure to take away care from
veterans i don't think so so go make
your voice heard today if you're in a
state that can vote
and even if you're not in a state that
can vote maybe you should register some
of your friends that aren't registered
or help them get registered
show them how go look it up
how do i register to vote in x state
and help your friends get registered
help your community members get
registered if you got a little extra
cash give some of these campaigns
some of that cash they need money
they're going to need money to help
people knock doors pay for water and a
little bit of food to give them energy
to go knock all these hundreds of
thousands of doors and speaking of that
go knock some doors
it's going to be great i promise you now
i know i know it's it's tuesday
and normally on tuesday at this time we
have texas paul but texas paul
could not join us today he had he had a
an event
that was pre-planned so i think he'll be
not back next tuesday so next tuesday
texas paul will join us
now he isn't able to join us this
tuesday but next tuesday i believe paul
will be able to join us here on the tony
michael's podcast we've we've had fun
with paul the last few weeks
on tuesdays
but right now we're gonna surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends so
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
the [ __ ] list roundup
yeah everyone's asking texas paul
everyone's a little sad texas paul's not
here on tuesday i think he's going to be
back next tuesday again he had some
prior engagements that he had
pre-planned so he wasn't able to join us
today this tuesday but i believe he's
going to be back next tuesday we're
going to make it a tuesday thing a texas
tuesday thing with texas ball
but he wasn't able to join us today
so yeah you just got me today
i ain't gabe's going to join us here at
the top of the hour i believe he's still
working on a few things
um so he's trying to get some things
done yesterday the noise and um
in his in his space there was preventing
him from doing certain work with the
microphone because of the noise so it
took him a little long to get here and
there and here and there
so
but yes texas paul is not joining us
today he will join us next week again he
had a a prior engagement
pre-plans
and he wasn't able to join us today but
he will he will come back next week i
believe when i talked to paul he said
he'd be back next week on tuesday
um which is and i'm excited about it i'm
excited for paul to join us every single
tuesday he always gives us a rundown not
just of texas but other news of how how
uh texas is affecting the country
so that's that's wonderful that's
wonderful that's what we need is
conversation about how how to advance
our democracy that's that's the main
point that's the main point so let's
surf the tweety tweets because i got a
lot of stuff i want to get to here i got
a ton of stuff i want to get to here a
lot of video i want to show you folks um
here is uh jimmy kennedy had it here
jimmy says and this is greg norman
complaining to tucker carlson about how
men
oh men just have it so bad you know i
don't know how much greg norman's worth
but this motherfucker's probably worth
damn near 7 800 million
he's worth all kinds of [ __ ] money
what the hell are you bitching about
money for and all this [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here jimmy says if you complain
in a national tv interview about your
salary from a golf course you're part of
the problem exactly
start building affordable housing on
these pieces of prime real estate
instead of indulging in a game of
small-minded capitalists thank you jimmy
jimmy points it out very eloquently
there well let's listen let's listen
just for a second because this is ah
this is a almost a minute long i don't
want to listen to this little [ __ ] come
whine and complain
to that rube tucker carlson more than i
have to but let's listen to greg norman
here
crying whine
about how
he had to take soddy money because he's
a greedy bastard here we go pga tour i
think has about 27 sponsors
on the pga tour do 40 plus billion
dollars worth of business on an annual
basis in saudi arabia
now why doesn't the pga tour call the
ceos of each one of those organizations
sorry we can't do business with you
because you're doing business with saudi
arabia
why are they picking on the professional
golfers
wait for it he says they're picking on
the professional golfers but it gets
deeper than that this is much different
than just picking on the golfers
because tiger woods turned down i i
think the report is 700 million
i'm not [ __ ] you tiger woods turned
down 700
million dollars to play in this term
think about that for a second
they were selling the tickets for a
dollar
on stubhub
a dollar
think about that what the male
professional the male yeah the man
females the lpga tour men are
responsible men are so oppressed oh my
god men are so oh my god they're the
most depressed class of people ever in
the history of ever ever
especially
the rich white ones oh my god can you
imagine
being a rich white man oh my god it
would be so
horrible
what the [ __ ] i'm not even gonna finish
listening to this stupid piece of [ __ ]
let me show you let me show you why
here you go
joe says it best here jojo from jurors
says the guy who
boasted about his building being the
tallest on 9 11 and later lied about
being at ground zener to help clear
rebel just hosted a saudi-backed blood
money
golf tournament and his private club
slash cemetery
and they gave out this [ __ ] trophy
look like anything to you what does this
look like this is the trophy they handed
out
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
i believe that the saudis paid all that
money
all of it
every single nickel
just for this troll right here
just to have
in america on trump's golf course hold
up a trophy that looks like
the rubble from 911.
everyone's seen the [ __ ] image
that's the trophy
this is a saudi troll
the whole entire thing
and the saudi prince doesn't give a [ __ ]
because donald trump loves him
that's it right there that's the [ __ ]
trophy
i don't know maybe maybe maybe just
maybe donald trump will get another
trophy and put it up on his ex-wife's
grave over in the ditch
off the first fairway this is [ __ ]
gross folks this is [ __ ] gross
it's it's [ __ ] disgusting
it's vile
that
and to top it all off top it off greg
norman's on on tucker carlson's white
privilege tonight
whining and crying about how these guys
are oppressed
the [ __ ] out of here the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] it's enough of this
whining and crying from rich white men
i'm so sick of that [ __ ]
as if they're oppressed trust me i'm a
i'm a white dude and we are not
oppressed not a thing
[ __ ] out of here that nonsense
um
i had another i thought i had another
video here of the uh
of the
oh yes everyone's seen this
picture oh someone i forget who someone
tweeted did they have a [ __ ] a
hamburger gun like a t-shirt gun that
they were firing off into the crowd
that's why oh hamburgers look at this
guy
look at this guy what the [ __ ]
this is their leader this is it
this is the guy where they're like oh
he's so cool
he's such a hip guy but look what hal
sparks writes that's the reason why i
tweeted this
i know i know there's a lot of sparklers
in the audience here and i don't know if
hal is live right now i have no idea if
hal is alive right now no clue maybe is
maybe isn't i don't know i keep don't
keep get keep track of uh hal's
um streaming schedule but i know i know
we have a lot of sparklers here in our
audience
which i'm a fan of hal
and hal says i'm starting to think the
rambo flag is photoshopped oh my god
of course that flag is photoshopped look
at this [ __ ] broom
look at this guy
oh [ __ ] you remember the um
uh
you remember the uh what what what was
the nazi rally they had in texas was it
that was it the nra nazi rally they had
after 19 children were slaughtered and
two teachers in uvalde they were like
yeah we're gonna we're gonna step over
the dead bodies and have a have a
convention about the guns that
slaughtered and tore apart those
children
to promote more sales of more mass
murderers killing more children we'll do
that in texas i think it was there where
they had this it was a cell phone
company had a [ __ ] like a rambo cut
out
but this guy's face super people were
taking pictures of it i wonder if they'd
take a picture of a cardboard cutout
that's what we should do
that's what we should do somebody
anybody you can hear my voice if you can
if we can figure out a way to make a
cardboard cut out i will make i will
[ __ ] make a cardboard cutout just
like this
contact me get my dms let's make a
cardboard cutout just like this
see if then
ah someone get walter mattresses on the
good liars they're the greatest trolls
on earth at these events maybe they can
take a cardboard cutout
of this to see if people will [ __ ]
take a picture of him like this
oh hal sparks thank you very much for
the laugh this morning now speaking of
trump supporters um and the election and
this is this is a great video from beto
uh chris reposted it here chris said
people have been asking if that o'rourke
is also meeting and listening to
republican voters in his town halls
throughout texas the answer is yes yes
he is
listen to this gentleman here uh speak
about beto o'rourke i've been a lifelong
republican voter actually voted for
donald trump absolutely 100 veto
supporter um
he's very intelligent he has well
thought out you know approaches and you
spend a little time listening to him
take a little time and listen to what
his has to say about these different
issues because
it's not right or left it's about texas
and that's what we need to hear we don't
hear that out of great apple i bet if
texas paul was on today and i showed him
this video which i i
that would be great maybe i'll show it
to him next week when he comes on to see
what his thoughts are here but this is
this is super important folks this is
what i was talking about in the first
half hour
this is what i was talking about when i
said that this is a fraud
a people in this country the half the
country is loyal to trump that's a
[ __ ] fraud that's the biggest fraud
that we've ever had just like his
[ __ ] nazi rallies that he does his
manga nazi rallies
it's all the same [ __ ] that
show up i mean there you know there's a
few locals that that end up joining
but they're flying these people all over
the country the same [ __ ]
standing behind him every time they just
shuffle him around a little bit
there's not even that many people at
these [ __ ] things jesus christ i i
mentioned that they were selling the the
the uh the saudi blood money tournament
at trump cemetery
they were selling the tickets for a
dollar because they couldn't get anyone
to show up at that [ __ ]
because the only people that would show
up are [ __ ] traitors or trolling
traders as we saw the the good liars
doing to phil mickelson listen listen to
what else this guy's has to say
about beto this is super important folks
just seemed to get progressively and
progressively far more extreme far away
from the republican party that i
remember you know as a younger person so
that is super important
this is a guy who voted for trump
twice
and after january 6
after embracing
white christian nationalism after
embracing this america first nazism [ __ ]
this guy's like whoa this is not a
resemblance of the republican party i
remember
in 2016
yeah we were in deep [ __ ] with donald
trump but not inside the party inside
the talk
there wasn't this craziness i mean you
got to go back if you were lying the
clock rewind the clock back to 2016
trump wasn't saying the [ __ ] he's saying
about the lgbtq community he wasn't he's
changed his rhetoric
because the tail is wagging the dog and
the nazis have a hold of their party and
that's what this guy's saying
just because they were willing to vote
for trump because he was a republican
nominee like rusty bowers this house
speaker said after his testimony against
trump said he would vote for him and now
it's tuck tail and run that's why all
these other people run
from him and this video here this video
here gives other people in texas
permission
to be for democracy
to be for democracy because that's what
this guy's talking about here
he's talking pro-democracy things
you know he says it's not left it's not
right it's it's you know the
the republican party isn't the same
party they're now more extreme greg
abbott has become more extreme
he's talking about pro-democracy stuff
that's the message
i really had to take a hard look at
myself take a hard look at what i
believed and
what i supported and i just found myself
a position where i
could not support that side of the aisle
anymore absolutely a lifelong republican
voter and i am voting for beto award for
governor state of texas
pro-democracy folks that's the message
that's what we got to do that's how you
do it right there now thank you chris
for retweeting us and thank you to beto
o'rourke for going around and being
pro-democracy in texas
i want to mayo has a really important
piece of news here tucker carlson is a
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
i love mayo mayo is one of my favorite
here thank you for
for all your content that you that you
post mail we we all appreciate it uh
speaking of tucker carlson being a piece
of [ __ ] here you go
here it is she's not lying i got the
proof i got the proof that mayo
the mail's correct here you go
if a speech boasting that he's killed an
al-qaeda figure in afghanistan right
boosting oh he's pounding his chest
what a piece of [ __ ] i can't believe he
not only did he kill the al-qaeda leader
but now he's bragging about it
can you [ __ ] imagine can you even
[ __ ] imagine
what that that his orange mussolini
jesus would be saying if he actually got
off his [ __ ] ass and did some goddamn
work put his [ __ ] shoes on in the
morning and did some work and would have
smoked out the al qaeda leader get the
[ __ ] out of here and tucker carlson
would be groveling at trump's feet if
trump would have just done the work the
[ __ ] out of here
feel safer of course you don't
nobody does and the reason nobody what
are you talking about you dummy
it's look listen listen folks
when
when joe biden got us out of afghanistan
last summer
last summer
part of the country didn't even know we
were still in afghanistan
tucker
a big majority of americans had no
[ __ ] clue they had separated
themselves so much
from the idea that we were at war that
they didn't even realize until joe biden
pulled us out of afghanistan that we
were still there
it's the truth
it's the [ __ ] truth
it's the reason why republicans thought
they could vote against veterans
because america doesn't pay attention
that's why we have to [ __ ]
participate at every measure and we have
to engage with our strategic outrage to
save our democracy to make these people
pay attention
it wasn't until joe biden actually left
afghanistan that half the country went
whoa you mean we're still in afghanistan
holy
they had no clue
no clue
and i know it feels like i'm knocking on
other people
but i'm not they just didn't know they
had no clue they're not engaged in this
type of stuff like you like my audiences
my audience comes here every day and
engages in their democracy
every single day you guys engage
but some people do not and that's okay
but it's important for you to engage to
get them engaged it's super
super important do you feel safer
is biden's response to the disaster in
afghanistan
rather than pause and learn from it
maybe fire the people responsible for it
not simply the self-destructive
withdrawal from afghanistan but also the
pointless 20-year war there rather than
do any of that like a normal person
would do biden immediately set off in
another direction provoking yet another
conflict
oh my god okay so i don't know if you
know where this is going
okay
there's a lot of history in afghanistan
with the afghans
the taliban
al qaeda and russians
a lot of history
a lot
a [ __ ] ton
most of those uh
domestic terror that the terrorists
in domestically in afghanistan are
people who fought against russia or
their families fought against russia
invasion in afghanistan
there's a lot of history between
afghanistan and russia
a lot
and tucker carlson here
is going to say
that joe biden is somehow weak
by by by making sure to to kill
the number two who was in charge
under
osama bin laden who is now the leader of
al qaeda the organization who flew the
planes into the towers
during 911 who killed thousands of
people in new york
hundreds of people in washington at the
pentagon
and dozens and dozens of people on a
plane in pennsylvania
tucker carlson is now taking the side
of saudi arabia and russia here listen
to what the [ __ ] he is gonna say
listen
this one in eastern europe and he
provoked it they lie about it but it's
true the facts are out there and it's
very obvious so just days after the
russian government announced yet again
that if ukraine joined nato they didn't
even want ukraine to join
but if ukraine were to join nato then
the russian army would invade ukraine
so days after they said this for like
the 50th this is all lies by the way
this is all [ __ ] lies
all of it the entire [ __ ] thing
is lies and that's why mayo is right
tucker carlson is a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and again folks this is so important
when
you know we talk about democrats
messaging and pro-democracy messaging
is this garbage that tucker carlson's
doing here the [ __ ] that he's doing
where he asks stupid questions and he
just lies and says [ __ ] that sounds like
it could be true but it's not true at
all
all the gaslighting all the lying all
the nonsense it works
it works folks and the reason why it
works is because it appeals
to their predisposed no predisposed
notion
and these people want fascism
they want trumpism
but tucker carlson
mayo is right and i know gabe sanchez my
my executive producer will agree with me
tucker carlson is a piece of [ __ ] that's
what mayo says oh it's a huge piece of
[ __ ]
oh i mean
i mean if there was a bigger piece of
[ __ ] it would probably be that scene in
jurassic park where jeff goldblum goes
that's a big pile of [ __ ] i what you
know speaking i got a lot of video game
to show do you have time you got the
rest of the you're at the top of the
hour you got a whole nother hour here
yeah yeah you got me you got me until
11.
and then i got it and then i gotta run
down over to the bunker and i gotta go
okay
i let the guys take a
a late start today
because we really worked into the night
we were drilling we were digging we were
really did you guys get more soros
checks then did you get more we did we
did yeah yeah so
you could continue working exactly yeah
yeah i gave them a little extra you know
change so they could buy some sandwiches
or some you know breakfast burritos or
whatever this morning so
you know what you know
you with the wii u with the breakfast
burritos you know what's funny about all
this the soros talk
yeah
is you know they always say this [ __ ] in
the comments you know that were paid by
the deep state i get this a lot i am
paid by the deep state right the deep
state has deep pockets i'm just saying i
don't know about you tony but they got
deep pockets i haven't got my [ __ ]
but it was more on tick-tock than
anything yeah i actually i actually felt
like though those trolls were more
you know
steeped in the whole george soros
language this yeah
during during leading up to the 2020
election and into
2021
there was definitely a ton i feel like
there was more deep state soros
talk back then because everyone was
thinking like the great awakening it's
gonna be barron trump that comes back
from the [ __ ] future and it's he's
gonna be the one that is the supreme
ruler and donald trump was leading up to
it okay okay you're hurting i'm losing
iq points i'm losing iq points i know
and that's not craziest one either well
here's the thing here's the thing
is today we find out that tiger woods
tiger woods turned down 700
million dollars of blood money from the
saudis to play in this tournament wow
and now again again they always [ __ ]
yell and scream about george soros and
the cabal is paying money
to control these people and here the
saudi government
the saudis yeah the blood money that
they have
is being used to buy and pay for these
golfers i mean it's not just yeah it's
it's murder money is what it is right
exactly
absolutely
and and they used the former president
of the united states to prop it all up
at his at his cemetery at bedminster
right this is [ __ ] absolutely crazy
well i had to code on it and you weren't
able you you were gone couldn't couldn't
interview i was underground
right but me and dakota talked about how
he like came to this realization
eventually that he was like you know
this the new world order stuff was like
all the talk when he was a kid with this
militia like that's all it was new world
order and deep state and it's all the
same rooted [ __ ] and he's like it's all
projection
oh yeah 100 he's like he's like i didn't
realize it until within the last 18
months but he's like every single bit of
the new world order is exactly what they
want that's what they've wanted this
whole time
they've accused people of having this
this this cabal that was going to
control everyone in the world because
that's what they wanted like they kept
well i i think i think it yes it is
definitely that is it is always 100
their own projection of wants and
desires it's the same reason why they go
after people or what they're actually
doing or what they're right exactly i
mean it's it's the very same reason why
they go after people in the lgbtq
community where they're like oh we want
to rule and we want to tell you what you
can do in your own household because
right now and probably for the
you know for the future we won't be able
to so we want to get off on telling you
what to do and right and [ __ ] busting
through your door when you are you know
getting it on or whatever you're doing
but i think that
it's it is that projection it is that
where almost to a degree that it's
it's like they almost feel like they
to me it feels like they want to be
invited right like they're the kids in
on the playground that were never picked
first they were always picked last or
never picked at all right
because no one wanted to hang around
them probably right exactly they're you
know they're super cringed very awkward
you know these kids that i feel like
that is that those are those people
right or it's the
you know uh i was doing i'm doing a deep
dive for the what was that on matt gates
and some of the stuff that i pulled up
from his childhood and his former
classmates everyone's like oh yeah he
was an [ __ ] he was entitled he
thought it was better than everyone he
was a rich kid he didn't have friends
you know he joined the debate team to
like be uh
so that he could actually have like a
cooler persona whatever everyone's like
he was actually an emotional vampire and
that's what i think a lot of republicans
are are emotional wait they said the
quote they said yeah yeah they said they
they said not only wasn't he
uh he an [ __ ] but he was also an
emotional vampire and that's what i
think a ton of republicans are is it
takes a lot of effort to actually have a
conversation with them the republican
party is a cult but they are all
energy-sucking
vampires that is what they do and
they're projecting their own wants and
desires onto
uh other people because they want to one
either be invited and they never were
invited
or two if they want to take what other
people have
and then use it for themselves right so
they they want the cabal they want the
baby blood cells right right right that
[ __ ] well you know what you know what's
funny though is i showed a a video
yesterday of kevin sorbo's wife i think
her name is sarah sorbo or something and
she was talking about she didn't even
know he was married by the way just want
to point that out did not know that she
was on sebastian gorka's show which is a
problem in and of itself but they were
talking about how raising uh people
raising their hand to ask to speak or to
ask a question oh sometimes you're right
what the [ __ ] like just just the plain
simple fact that these people try to
sound intelligent
and they're not they're not at all right
it gets stupider and stupider and
stupider it's it's also the fact that
when she's like oh this whole like razor
hand thing
is it's like no it's just called having
manners right i when i was in a class i
was told that you have to wait your turn
and that you raise your hand if you have
a point that you want you have to speak
over someone right it's [ __ ] decency
and the other thing too is to say that
raising your hand is discouraging people
from having their own ideas like that's
the actual action of it right like
that's to say i have a question or i
have a comment right and maybe the time
between you raising her hand and you
getting picked on like you have a moment
to back out of that offer right where
you have enough time to then think
um should i should i say what i'm about
to say see but this is the thing this is
the thing
we lose iq points by going down these
rabbit holes just like this [ __ ] one
here again
on newsmax and you have you have bobo
the clown
probably in contention for the dumbest
member of congress but there's so many
of them right now that it's hard to it
would be a tough contest but listen to
what she she's talking about gabe she's
talking about dog treats and tyrannical
governments here i'm not [ __ ] you
listen to this nonsense populist if the
citizenry in america is disarmed then we
are no longer citizens we are okay so
first off if we're disarmed we're not
citizens i don't know if she means
literally or what she's talking about
here i don't know i mean maybe she's
like you're not citizens in this
tyrannical
regime like i i don't know i don't know
if you don't have a gun that you don't
serve a purpose
like 99.9 percent of people even if they
own guns they don't can carry in public
because it's dangerous as [ __ ] to carry
there's a reason why the landlord of her
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah kicked her
out
there's this whole thing i mean i i
clipped out a segment of this interview
yesterday juicy because i was like this
is all [ __ ] lie i need to fact check
this [ __ ] right in this interview here
it was this interview you mean it's
dumber than this oh well it's her claim
i'll find i'll get my i'll get my okay
well let me let me play the rest of this
because it gets
it gets dumber and dumber and dumber as
she speaks i mean it's just
dumb as dog [ __ ] here no pun intended
when she starts talking about dog treats
subjects you know here in america we
have
gourmet treats for puppies
so she went from
i mean i'm all over the map game i'm
always all over the map
i'll admit it here on the tony michael's
podcast i'm all yeah we're looking we're
we're tr we're making connections and
and tangential you know points here and
there but this is crazy this is so she
goes from if you can't if you don't have
a gun you're not a citizen too we make
gourmet puppy treats i don't understand
where she's going with it i don't like i
mean i don't figure this out
okay people make it's a it's a billion
dollar industry why wouldn't you have to
worry about puppy street we got [ __ ]
we got warehouse stores that are full of
puppy treats designed to take your money
for puppy treats what's the what's the
with guns but listen she tries to draw
it to guns we have uh these amazing
groomers for dogs well in venezuela oh
which groomers the dogs and they eat the
dogs in venezuela now okay okay so i
showed this video to my wife last night
because i was like can you understand
what the [ __ ] she's trying to say here
i couldn't figure i'm like what in the
[ __ ] is she trying to say is she's
trying to say that because you need guns
to hunt so that you're not eating your
own dog or some [ __ ] i can't figure out
what the [ __ ] she's trying to say
she couldn't figure it out either
yeah but she asked me she's like do they
eat dogs in venezuela i'm like i i don't
know i don't i don't know what she's
talking about like i don't know if she
means like there's a heavy poverty so so
people have to
well she did you know she does like to
tell her story about how she lived on
government welfare and was eating
government cheese and how it didn't help
her and stuff like that you know oh so
it kept her alive but you know it didn't
work right right exactly
um well let's
get i'm telling you there's only there's
only about 10 seconds left in this thing
but this 10 seconds gets dumber than the
first 20 seconds and it started because
they don't have firearms they do not
have a way to protect themselves to
defend themselves against a tyrannical
government uh so
wha
what so dog sorry what was that
dog
dog treats in america
pup gourmet puppy treats in america
uh-huh we have those here you know yeah
i mean i guess that's true in other
countries too probably better gourmet
treats in other countries probably but
venezuela because there may been someone
who ate a dog
that's the reason why we have to have
guns here because
of dog treats and tyrannical i don't
know what the [ __ ] she's trying to say
is she trying to say if we don't own
guns but we have puppy treats that the
government's going to be taran i can't
figure it out i seriously lost i lost at
least at least
several hundred brain cells trying to
figure this out i'm gonna ask it i'm
gonna ask a question now is this in any
way related to the 2020 election in hugo
chavez uh it could be that could be is
it is dominion voting systems are they
pumping out gourmet puppy treats
instead of guns
like is that what's going on this is
insanity it's absolute i just can't
i can't i can't stop well here is um you
posted something i think from this
interview is that what you're sending me
here yeah you got it yeah um and this is
a video that you would post i think it's
from the is it from the same interview
she's on the same interview
okay so show the video and then we'll uh
okay okay
yeah okay well this is after are you
directing or in my number look look
picture and roll okay so
uh this is right after she goes on a
little bit of a rant to say how
government welfare or aid programs don't
actually help and she grew up getting
government welfare and in government
cheese as she likes to say and several
interviews she's done over the years she
says i lived on government cheese and it
didn't help me and so then i got a job i
wonder if she actually knows the the
story behind government cheese why the
government gave out cheese yeah i think
she knows the story i i doubt she does
but she thinks that she does she think
that she did you think that she knows
that and it's probably we could go find
the tweets where she's in support of the
dairy farmers like the reason why the
government had so much [ __ ] cheese is
because we subsidized the dairy market
right 100
bought into the america the american
government bought into the dairy market
to prop them up to have dirt which is
not a bad thing i don't think it's a bad
thing but that's why we had so much
goddamn cheese because the government
actually bought the cheese and the
reason why they bought the cheese is
because it was an easy way to preserve
that dairy like it was a way to preserve
that dairy and distribute it because
milk goes bad very quickly cheese not so
much that's why they that's why they
bought it in cheese
so she doesn't even she doesn't even
know she doesn't she doesn't even know
the story behind government change which
is [ __ ] not right well you know the
other thing too is
when it comes to subsidies though the
united states does [ __ ] the bed for
other countries when they subs because
they say
let's say like it's jamaica and it's you
know which is a it's a high um a high
tourist uh area
um you know they're a grain export right
but they had more grains coming out
earlier before the us started starting
to over produce grains and then say
hey region's in the surrounding area
we're going to give you this at a lower
cost so when you're
offering
grains and rice and things like that
pennies on the dollar to what the local
economy offers it you basically blow
their economy up and we we've done that
in other countries as well where other
countries like we don't we don't need
your help don't do this because you're
going to ruin what we already have
right so if it's locally yeah you know
for dairy and stuff that works but if
it's other countries uh we have really
[ __ ] to bed and [ __ ] over other like
local economies
but in this example she goes from
i was on government cheese to
um i then learned that i should
uh get a better job and work at
mcdonald's and i wanted to do better you
know and then like and then and then she
goes and then i fast and then fast
forward and boom and this is where we
are right now
well let's le it's only 17 seconds so
yeah i have a husband four wonderful
boys and a restaurant and a lot of
employees vendors patrons that i needed
to take care of and i saw the second
amendment um to be the best line of
defense to make sure everyone was kept
stay safe in my establishment
what wait wait wait a second wait a
second how many what what kind of what
who goes into a sandwich shop
and and get like you know what you know
what i'm gonna do i don't understand i
don't understand like this is her
mentality she has a mass shooter
mentality this is the problem this is
the problem these [ __ ] idiots like
her have mass shooter mentalities where
she's like you know what if i had to
solve a problem about a restaurant down
the street do you know what i would do i
would go in and i would start shooting
on those people that's what that's
that's what the mass shooter mentality
would do they think they can solve any
problem with a gun and because she
thinks she can solve any problem with
the gun
her first instinct is hey what if
someone else who is crazy as i am who
would solve any problem that they have
with a gun what if they come into my
restaurant so i better have guns here so
i can solve the problem that i caused by
this problem this problem they come here
solve their problem with the gun so then
i gotta solve a problem with the gun
this is this is the this is the mass
shooter mentality that we have
established with these maga yeah trump
pumping nazis
well it's like that example i gave uh
last week or the week before which was i
think it was last week
or maybe before i forget uh but it was
the example which was at the mall you've
got a mass shooter and a guy who's open
carrying goes hey i'm going to save the
day comes out goes pee pee pew
someone else doesn't see the original
shooter and goes that's the bad guy whoa
he's the shooter pew pew right and then
another yeah
and then the cops show up and they're
like everyone's dead it's a big gun
circle jerk but that's again that's the
mentality it's the mass shooter
mentality that we have a stat that the
gun manufacturers and the nra have
established in our country uh you wrote
here about this uh this little clip
lauren balbard is married to a guy who
exposed his penis to minors
in a bowling alley in a bowling alley
while she was there by the way and then
she married him after the fact uh may
and she wasn't she underage when he did
it mm-hmm
okay
um mate are four boys posed with guns
for a christmas card days after school
shooting
and this is and that was that was in
response to massey posting a photo of
his family on his couch with a gun
and she was like hey i could do one
better cool so cool to project that mass
shooter mentality right onto your
christmas days after the oxford high
school shooting should they were like
yeah you know what we need santa needs
to bring us more ammo correct yourselves
you say is a monster quote
that's based on her employees
unemployment
meaning that is an actual quote from her
that is an actual quote from former
employees she's a [ __ ] monster
because she also
i was going to say who also uh they said
pointed a gun
at an obama supporter at the restaurant
who
yeah wait she got her [ __ ] firearm
out and pointed at someone i thought it
was for protection
i thought it was for protection i didn't
think it was for intimate it's almost
like i'm correct when i say mass shooter
mentality
um
she gave diarrhea uh to her customers
which um you know you actually did a
little video on that um a while back and
um
smash mouth actually responded to it
hell no right that's another day another
dollar um doesn't have a rat anymore
and is a racist she is and there's a lot
of things right she's uh an
insurrectionist
she is just
this doesn't even like bring in the tax
liens that were against their business
from 2000. that's what the
unemployment's about that's what the
unemployment is exactly and then there
was a whole mileage fraud thing where
she was like miscalculation they're like
it's some that's not something you
miscalculate
right well the thing the thing about the
unemployment um where that comes in is
that um she isn't paying the
unemployment tax because in most states
most states um
when you have an unemployment insurance
the employee pays part of the insurance
and the employer pays part of the
insurance uh the premium that the state
has for if you get unemployed that's the
insurance that you have that the state
pays you so much per month
um you know every state's a little
different because it's a state to state
thing
but from my understanding of state of
colorado
she didn't pay her portion of the
employment tax and she also didn't give
the portion of the employees
employment unemployment premium so when
when uh when an employer pays you and
again this goes back to the inflation
and [ __ ] recession [ __ ] that i've
been talking about where uh during the
pandemic americans realize that we get
to trade our labor for money and we do
not have to [ __ ] we do not have to
feel feel like we're doing the
corporation or of the employer a favor i
mean that they're doing us a favor we're
doing them a favor by trading them their
labor but when you trade your labor to a
restaurant like this and she has to pay
you
she she's by law she's required to the
employer being lauren robert is required
to actually uh portion out and pay the
state your portion and her person of
that unemployment insurance and that's
where she's getting in trouble with the
state of colorado um is with that
unemployment
the list the list is long there is a ton
of stuff that lauren bobert has done or
failed to do
whether it's incompetency or just her
being a bonehead or dumb or whatever it
might be this was literally all i could
fit in that tweet in 280 characters or
whatever i was like all right this is
what i can put in there based on
addressing creativity exactly yeah i was
well i only wanted and this one i only
want i wanted to i wanted to leave the
rest for other people if they wanted to
go for it they could go for it but i
needed to address the exact things that
she brought up her husband her kids her
restaurant her employees
all of that stuff
so
why i've got i want to do a rapid round
here with you yeah yeah i got a lot of
video i want to show that i just yeah i
want to get it on air here um so let's
do a wrapping around let me start with
make sure i don't miss the one that
anyone the ones that i want um
let's let's start with uh von hilliard
challenging carrie lake on her [ __ ]
line speaking of challenging someone on
their [ __ ] lies about elections now
carrie lake is running for governor of
arizona she's a [ __ ] liar she lies
about election fraud she claims she has
evidence she hasn't provided evidence to
anyone or anywhere
nothing publicly has she's been able to
show where there's any kind of elections
i've been able to say that on the debate
stage with other people
right well here's the craziest part is
this is a broadcast of a trader news
network right so the camera and the
microphone
that you're hearing from is from real
america's voice this is the same stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] that that pumps out
steve bannon's trader tv [ __ ] right
right now this is important because
the guy you see the back of his head
here in the front this is vaughn
hilliard he works for msnbc he's a
reporter for msnbc and again this is
carrie lake who's going to be answering
questions from vaughn hilliard
but the tv camera and the microphone
picking it up is not msnbc
what is happening is
is that maga
these these let's go brandon nazis who
watch this trader tv
is going to watch von hillyard
pressure carrie lake into answering a
[ __ ] question it's beautiful it is
beautiful and i bet there is dozens and
dozens of people because that's really
probably all they have watching at any
given time
there's dozens of people who change
their mind about carrie lake just from
this little clip watch this
you're honoring contending that there's
a regularity that there is fraud in this
election at what point does kerry lake
stop and say am i undermining americans
faith in our elections
so there vaughn hilliard starts with the
question
it's very pointed she can answer very
simply
and again this microphone and they're
they're staying on this they're staying
on this which is very important on this
trader tv news network because this
reporter is holding a microphone here
uh but watch watch as she responds with
a lie and what ball and he healer does
every life is going to help bring back
his elections to america but you haven't
even laid out any fraud or a regular
bonds are about destroying america but
whatever what is their carries but what
fraud is there carrie what fraud is
there simple easy question about what is
straightforward you know no [ __ ]
let's get the answer
this is serious i want to make this
about you or do you want to make it and
this is about arizona voters and their
faith in this election last person on
the planet earth i would tell about what
we've discovered is you and ms
so you know about a crime and yet you're
not affording it to authorities and i'm
not telling you oh got him
she
[ __ ] she's he's if i when i know
about a crime i'm not going to tell you
and he says so you know about a crime
and you're not reporting it to
authorities because that's the rub here
that's the nonsense that's the [ __ ]
and that's what needs to leak through to
these [ __ ] hairbrained people who are
still being grifted right by the likes
of donald trump and carrie [ __ ] lake
i'm going to show you another video from
a carrie lake event here about some vile
piece of [ __ ] talking to the media uh
here in just a second it's more video i
want to show
but this von hilliard i applaud him um i
i've watched von for many many years
vaughn is an excellent reporter he asked
great questions and more reporters
need to treat republicans exactly
like von hilliard's treating him they're
treating carrie lake here you are a
[ __ ] liar you are full of [ __ ] and
and and that is what the american people
need to know that you're a lying
piece of [ __ ] i mean it's it's it's no
different than everyone else on the
republican side you see it in the
comments i was like oh there was fraud
that was farther from it's like okay
well if you have evidence then go to
your local law enforcement authority and
report it and if it really is real
they'll send it up the chain you know
it's for anyone else especially rudy
giuliani when they go into court and
they're like we have fraud and they're
like do you have evidence he's like
no
we don't have evidence we have theories
and it's like you can't do [ __ ] with
theories right just because you dreamt
about it doesn't mean it's all
projection gabe it's all projection from
carrie lake on down it's all projection
carrie lake the fake man
when are you gonna report it to
authorities
watch the end this is the greatest part
when they pan back to the actual
reporter who has the microphone the hot
mic here watch
fake news everybody fake news in the
house
so there is some fake news in the house
guys
so the producer in his here is like oh
man cut this off you got to tell them
this is fake or
there's like there's dozens of did he
specify which part was the fake news i
well you know that's they're like fake
news we got fake news in the house won't
tell you which one vote for eric not
gonna tell you which one if it's a
schmidt or is it greitens won't tell you
you'll just have to find out yourself
right right right you'll find out who
wins you'll find out who i support when
whichever eric wins speaking of
elections speaking elections this is a
senator doug jones former senator from
alabama
he's talking about the amendment in
kansas a lot of people are confused i've
seen some people in the comments here
about this kansas
referendum on the ballot today in kansas
listen to what doug jones has to say
about it and and spread this spread this
around because i think a lot of people
are confused about what that referendum
is that referendum is going to help
codify abortion rights in kansas but you
have to vote the correct way on that
referendum listen
hey folks there's a really important
election coming up in kansas and i hope
everyone will get out to vote
reproductive freedom is on the ballot in
kansas tomorrow yes that's right kansas
you have the ability to control your own
destiny unlike alabama oklahoma texas
with the state legislature has done it
for you women have this right tomorrow
it's on the ballot so here's the deal a
constitutional amendment is on the
ballot in kansas tomorrow that would
overturn a state supreme court a kansas
supreme court decision of a few years
ago that gave women the constitutional
right under the kansas constitution to
an abortion so let's be clear what doug
jones is saying and this is what
everyone in kansas if you're in kansas
or you know someone in kansas that's
gonna vote you need to make sure to make
clear to them is what this referendum
does is overturn
the decision of the supreme court in
kansas
deeming the abort the right to abortion
for women in kansas constitutional so
this referendum does not you do not want
to vote yes on this referendum you want
to vote no on this referendum because it
is a referendum that is going to try to
overturn
your rights in kansas they literally put
a referendum on the ballot to overturn
rights disguising it as one that
wouldn't but listen to doug jones here
listen to control their own reproductive
rights
this
amendment tomorrow would overturn that
it would allow state legislature your
state legislature in kansas to go the
way of texas and oklahoma and alabama
and all of the other states that are
taking that right away from you after
the roe versus wade decision was
overturned this is incredibly important
we've seen an incredible surge of voter
registrations in kansas uh after that
decision that the road decision came
down
so now this is the opportunity kansas
this is a big deal this is an
opportunity to control your own destiny
you need to vote no vote no on this
amendment your lives your freedoms your
economy all of that is on the line
tomorrow
so go vote no on this amendment in
kansas again uh spread this video around
uh get as many people as you know to
to hear what that uh that referendum
that amendment uh is
where it's it's gonna give the
the right to the legislator to overturn
your rights uh in the state of kansas
don't let them take the ability to
overturn your rights um let's listen to
more stupidity again as we go through a
wrapping around here this is tom cotton
racist
skeleton crew nazi tom cotton here on
fox news on fascist tv um let's listen
to what he says about about
biden
is unwilling to stand up to china by
standing up the cha i'm not really sure
how this works but let's listen mayor
the american people deserve someone as
their commander in chief who may not
have or who doesn't have family members
potentially compromised by adversarial
regimes like the chinese communists
what what wait wait a second we're
saying tom cotton so you're saying
you're saying we need to have a
president we do we do not need to we
need to get rid of a president
whose family is tied to china
communist china because um we did that
already we actually um elected the other
guy
um and got rid of also doesn't want to
bring up any sort of attachment to you
know saudis right no you've got
absolutely
taken that murder money you've got uh
jared kushner taking that 2 billion for
his
what about all those what about all
those uh um
trademarks that uh oh oh ivanka is
getting in check oh yeah
i bet hunter biden's laptop is going to
do a press conference this afternoon
disputing disputing these chinese
allegations uh speaking i hear you can
buy some good uh trump gear out of china
too
can you really oh it's
[Laughter]
it's not shitty because of where it's
manufactured it's shitty because trump
doesn't lose
exactly makes it or how it's made or
what the quality is
he wants it as cheap as possible that
way you can sell it for high profits for
his grip
um here is an actual president of the
united states doing actual president
things you know putting on his [ __ ]
shoes in the morning getting up and
doing the job even if he has coveted
he's doing his job maybe a bike ride
maybe an ice cream cone who knows right
well yeah yeah well i mean he can
actually get on a bike you know right
that's true
let's let's listen to the president
united states describe how he killed the
lieutenant of osama bin laden the leader
of al-qaeda make it clear again tonight
that no matter how long it takes
no matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people the
united states will find you
and take you out
after relentlessly seeking zawahiri
for years under presidents bush obama
and trump
our intelligence community located
zawahiri earlier this year
it moved to downtown kabul to reunite
with members of his immediate family
after carefully considering
a clear and convincing evidence of his
location
i authorized a precision strike that
would remove him from the battlefield
once and for all
this mission was carefully planned
rigorously minimize the risk of harm to
other civilians
and one week ago
after being advised the conditions were
optimal i gave the final approval to go
get him
and the mission was a success
none of his family members were hurt and
there were no civilian casualties
boom
president biden
smokes smokes terrorist thanks brandon
thanks a lot we really appreciate it i i
mean i i've seen some things that the
wright has been saying but this is a
hard one to spin against biden
especially because don jr was going out
on a [ __ ] rant yesterday he posted a
video to facebook and was like uh joe
biden is sick with covet again uh this
is the second time in three weeks like
that's he goes on about he's like maybe
buddy should take some more time off
because we are able to get more things
done when biden is away and it's like if
that was the case
then maybe this wouldn't have happened
who knows you know but it's like seems
like he's pretty effective even when
he's in or out of office with or without
covet right well when i say when i say
uh president biden smokes terrorists
literally look at the smoke here uh in
kabul this is a that's a video that cbs
news posted um from
from that's a pretty precise you know
based on it being a highly did you see
this didn't have like swords on it it
had like [ __ ] swords on it or some
[ __ ]
no i didn't i didn't i didn't know what
i was made of but i mean like respect
like
this is in downtown kabul like this is a
highly dense populated area
you know
obviously for the scale where it is
right now but i'm looking at like you
know what was accomplished here i'd say
it's
pretty precise on on on the target you
know which is great because there were
no civilian casualties there was no one
else from his family that was killed
he you know he as a threat was taken out
um
i just want to say i you know he rolled
him up and smoked him i mean it's
that's pretty much what happened he
rolled him up
smoked him like a philly joint okay uh
now speaking of rolling up and smoking
uh we have john stewart going after jack
um uh prostate here you guys know
he's a gay boy yeah he blocked me on he
blocked me on twitter
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know if he
didn't he didn't like me calling him out
a little chat
oh oh he was on a live chat on twitter
he was on a live he was on a twitter
live uh stream and i he was like hey
guys what's going on i'm gonna speak at
this conference and i was like that
conference is [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] fake
you're a fascist it probably was his
moderator take it easy on jack it was
probably his moderator
[Music]
little jackie sorry about that
our moderators our moderators are a lot
tougher than jackson yeah dude they
[ __ ] smoke
yeah right well
mj mj and minus robin are
are our moderators here and they do such
a great job give them a shout out
to our mods here um they do such a great
job and they do it
so
with so
less effort they they know exactly how
to handle these trolls right they know
exactly how to handle these trolls in
the chat so we appreciate our mods
because we don't even really notice the
trolls anymore because they're so
good
you know it's almost like they have the
precision ninja missiles themselves for
these trolls they're like you're in a
timeout you're in a timeout
calm down
three times you're out three strikes
you're out [ __ ] because we don't we
don't necessarily want to get rid of
trolls like i don't care with a troll
hanging around talking [ __ ] but
that's right but if you are being racist
or a bigot or attacking people in the
chat and just being an overall terrible
horrible all [ __ ] ground
you'll find out you [ __ ] around you're
gonna find out with our mods so thank
you to mj and midas rob and we
appreciate uh you being the the the
greatest mods on earth the greatest mods
on earth
so everyone give love to mj and minus
robin in the chat for doing such a great
job being a mod there um but here here's
the thing
speaking of trolls jon stewart goes
after jack prostate here um is that his
name says any prostate yes i think so
i think so
prostatitis yeah prosta prosthetic he's
a prostitute that's probably what he is
a prostitute i don't know look it up um
jack proselyte here gets confronted by
john stewart this is [ __ ] great this
gave me [ __ ] goosebumps i was like oh
man john stewart is gonna [ __ ] will
smith this song [ __ ] watch this
cause these people have suffered for 15
years because you're up there
oh my god look look at jon stewart is
ready to slap the absolute [ __ ]
at a jack proselyte here dude not
holding back oh no [ __ ] to give here
not one
watch this
not in good faith
why is john i'm not even against you
guys
what are you doing then what are you
doing yeah why do you have a [ __ ]
phone in your hand
for 15 years because you're [ __ ]
looking at them
[Laughter]
i love watching jackpots ladies get
called a [ __ ] troll
i'm not even against you guys then why
the [ __ ] are you up against his face
right and this is this is exactly what
i've been talking about since jon
stewart really started to [ __ ]
make a a scene about this
is that
folks everyone thinks that democrats
language and messaging is weak
we don't have to listen to the democrats
on the hill you can do it yourself jon
stewart is taking this
by the hand and walking the pack back
down to the senate floor basically with
his messaging he got on national tv and
said those [ __ ] referring to
republicans in the senate those
[ __ ] i think he said it three
or four times yeah he said those
[ __ ] the language can change
it's up to you to change it and for you
to accept the language because the
democrats are scared of language and
they're scared of messaging because they
don't want to fail if they want to you
know i don't think they should all play
polite and you know oh i take the high
moral ground here like it's something
that we need the only way to deal with
this [ __ ] is in their face and this is a
great example of calling these people
out for the [ __ ] that they're
spreading
about what we are trying to accomplish
and captain turp says that the best john
speaks america's rage because frankly
that is
i mean i know a lot of people leave the
the comment here at our show that it's
cathartic right but really it i mean
it's supposed to be cathartic but it
that righteous anger is i mean it needs
to save our democracy when when i see
this and i'm sure when a lot of people
in the comments or people watching who
are listening to see this there's
probably a collective
exhale where you say
thank you like jesus [ __ ] christ
thank you finally someone is willing to
say it
and not give two [ __ ] because they know
what they are fighting for
is the right thing
and the right thing
is just basic decent human care for
another person who is willing to serve
and lay down their life for your
security in this country
right you wanted that freedom
well guess what people served and gave
their lives for it so the least you can
[ __ ] do is give it back for the
people who come back who have been
injured
or harmed
due to doing that for you
here's another senator everyone keeps
saying democrats aren't trying to push
this bill over the edge this is one one
of the most conservative senators that
the democrats have john tester jon
tester is actually a co-sponsor this is
his bill
and he has not left washington yet and i
don't think he's going to and he gives
he has no [ __ ] to give here um here he
is on pbs newshour talking again about
the pact act we need to be able to meet
the needs of our veterans this bill it
was passed on june 16th is the same bill
and we need to get the folks to come to
the table and vote for it again because
health care that is delayed is health
care that is denied and that is exactly
what everyone needs to be saying the
health care that is delayed for these
for these veterans is health care that
is denied by these republicans
these republicans are denying these
veterans health care not delaying it
they're denying it they're denying them
the right to this health care and it
needs to be called out so i want to
thank senator tester there um because
we're calling them again
these are real people these are real
lives that are at stake because the
republicans are trying to play some
petty [ __ ]
game
juggling someone else's care
in the balance because they want to
[ __ ] own the libs and they want to
make sure that biden isn't actually as
successful as he can be during his
presidency
well the other thing they want too gabe
the other thing that they really want is
they want not just to own the libs but
they want to stall democrat
um um success here before the midterm
that's really what they're trying to do
yeah they're really going after the
democrats yes i guess not a that's not
going to be a [ __ ] topic anymore by
the time i actually i actually believe
that the idea that a recession is going
to be
the talk is another thing because it
just shows the pure absolute gaslighting
of republicans in this country
acting like inflation is the worst thing
that's ever happened to us in this
moment in history when now they're going
to complain about a recession
and gas prices going down like so you
wanted this and now it's here and you're
gonna blame it on the same person you
said what's the [ __ ] blame for the
other thing right americans are waking
up to this let me show you [ __ ] i'm
telling you i'm telling you people are
waking up to this nonsense
this is the daughters
of the guy i forget his name he i'll
find his name here after the fact um he
was charged he well he was charged in
the january six insurrection he went to
trial he's the first one to have a
conviction at trial not a conviction at
plea but a conviction at trial and he
was sentenced to seven and a half years
yep yesterday he was sentenced at a
federal courthouse this is his two
daughters outside the courthouse after
he's been sentenced to seven and a half
years listen to what they say about
donald trump um
to mark my dad as this horrible person
and then having him prosecuted like this
when somebody is maybe even able to get
elected again
she's talking about somebody i wonder
who she's talking about watch what her
sister says her sister her sister's like
no we're gonna [ __ ] say his name
um doesn't seem right to me
um trump deserves life in prison if my
father's in prison for this long boom
boom yep yeah guy guy refit is the guy
yeah guy red that that's right but yeah
i mean like
you know these these people you know
starting to cause like yeah like that
sucks that your dad did that you know it
was unfortunate you know clearly under
the guide and insight
in the inciting
narrative that trump and the rest of
republicans pushed forward
but yeah if if he got [ __ ] seven
years for going into the capital and we
have only seen just a bit
of what has been revealed from the
january 6 committee trump should most
definitely get [ __ ] longer than that
right obviously well it's it's a tough
road because we don't know how to handle
a former president
in terms of uh uh charging someone like
this
but if one guy gets seven [ __ ] years
then trump should be getting a [ __ ]
lifetime
that's right that's right and and here
is here is uh scott mcfarlane uh
reporting on this on this sentencing um
our friends get let's listen to um
his uh explanation of inside the
courtroom of what his daughters also
said inside the courtroom on record
errol i've listened to dozens of january
6th sentencings and plea hearings i've
never heard anything close to what you
just heard from guy refered's daughter i
have never heard a defendant or a family
member speaking at a sentencing
so sharply and demonstratively criticize
former president trump never heard a
defendant or a relative say donald trump
should be sent to prison or jail that
was a distinctive
unique moment just there from guy
reference daughter she spoke during the
sentencing today i was in the courtroom
and she spoke just briefly in fact she
was
quite overpowered by the moment she
needed some time to collect herself
before she spoke again but she gave
muted criticism of donald trump in the
court she argued her father wasn't a
leader that day as prosecutors had
alleged she said the person whose name
was on the flags in the mob was the
leader boom
boom
there you go
guy guy reference daughter gets what's
going on and i'm telling you folks
telling you this january six select
hearings are having a massive effect a
massive effect in this country so much
so that even these people who went to
the capitol to try to save donald trump
and crown him king
uh are turning tucktail and turning and
running um i want to also get back to
some of this uh troll video
i don't mean to jump topics here again
yeah yeah but well actually you know
what let's let's uh let's talk about uh
consequence culture for a second alan
dershowitz is still [ __ ] complaining
that he can't go speak at a library i'm
not gonna play all this but let's play a
little bit of this um i've been banned
by the chill martial okay that's enough
um
[Laughter]
that's enough that's all i need to hear
him yeah [ __ ] him we'll cancel him here
this is more of this [ __ ] where there
where they're talking about consequence
culture there's complaining about being
canceled because they've made certain
decisions in their life and they've done
certain things support certain people uh
uh molested certain children allegedly
um
and supported pedophiles actual
pedophiles not the [ __ ] mystical
cabal ones and you're gonna pay for it
you're gonna pay for it those
consequences are heavy when you when you
do that kind of [ __ ] in public alan
dershowitz so why don't you just do this
why don't you shut the [ __ ] up and move
on and just and just call it a day no
one wants to hear from you and stop no
one even wants to hear you complaining
about your [ __ ] [ __ ] on trader tv
news network um speaking of trader tv
news networks i want to show you this
tape back to jon stewart for a second i
know i'm jumping around but i'm trying
to get all these videos in here gabe
this is no i get it gotta do this is
this is jon stewart again on newsmax now
he went on the other day and he had to
tell a little bit of truth but he still
it still is not seeping through
on newsmax let's listen great must work
with republicans and fix this issue to
prevent inflationary spending that will
hurt all americans once that happens the
pact act will quickly become law before
you react i just want to ask you too i'm
sure you've read about versus mandatory
spending
that seems to be what has changed they
did have the 80 do you see the
difference here between the video that
ted cruz did about this and then the
video that jon stewart yeah i mean i
don't know how many takes it took ted
cruz to get his hand in his pocket out
of his pocket and say look john uh you
know you might not understand there's
400 billion of discretionary you know
funding you know and he's like shut the
[ __ ] up right
i would just
that night that the video so jon stewart
uh had the tweets
i went in to go see a movie
and right before i went in ted cruz had
dropped that video right and then and i
like oh boom i will retweet that video
great cool but right as i walked in and
i was like oh man i can't wait for the
response that jon stewart has and of
course he [ __ ] dragged him through
and he was like this is why you're wrong
again it was voted on june 16th nothing
has changed you keep [ __ ] trying to
play politics here
and make it seem like something's
different nothing's different you
already voted for it
so
don't you think though don't you think
though that ted cruz could have just not
i mean what he wanted to have was a
twitter battle to increase his brand
like jon stewart's not trying to
increase his brand here he doesn't need
to that's that's why he's down here with
the veterans with his cell phone doing a
[ __ ] interview on newsmax with his
cell phone where while he's standing
here with these veterans trying to get
this thing passed while ted cruz is
staying in a hotel somewhere pro he's
standing in front of a hotel curtain i
can only imagine what kind of [ __ ]
fundraiser he was going to that night
right or had been at that night before
they shot that thing or you know when he
was right right yeah what kind of
[ __ ] money he was trying to raise to
[ __ ] take health care away from
veterans that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] but
here here jon stewart is on his cell
phone giving some truth listen this is
great because he just totally picks
apart their [ __ ] stupid argument like
look
ted cruz is smart enough to go the
website he's smart enough to know the
[ __ ] vote bill he's voting on today
with the same [ __ ] bill months ago
right e414 vote and then once that
changed
many republican votes changed um your
reaction sir
first of all i'm glad he wrote it down
because sometimes when people just lie
orally it's very hard to pin them down
so what i would ask you and it's sort of
what i asked you last time you said
something there that i think is the key
sentence
you said
when they changed the discretionary to
mandatory after the june vote
that's when the senator switched
and i keep trying to tell you this and
this is not an opinion this is a fact
go on congress.gov
the bill that they voted for 84 to 14
had the exact same provisions that they
are complaining about in it so i would
ask you to ask senator cruz to point to
the change you can look at the bill side
by side the bill that they passed on
june 16 84 to 14 did not have one word
added to it to the bill that
they shot down in july there was no
gimmick inserted there was no change
from mandatory to discretionary it is
utter nonsense i appreciate the
fear-mongering as someone who responds
very well to fear-mongering and gets
scared but that is just factually
incorrect and one of the biggest
problems we are having with this bill
is the misinformation that comes out of
supposedly credible sources like senator
ted cruz so please don't wait when did
ted cruz become a supposedly credible
source i've never looked at him as a
incredible source of anything of
anything
i mean not anything john's giving john's
being nice here he really is being nice
what he should have done here is gone
all jack prosthetic on it on this
[ __ ] right yeah yeah he should
have done i mean it's you know he you
pointed out earlier he doesn't care he's
there in front of the people he's there
on the [ __ ] ground
fighting for this the same reason why
he's like dude i don't [ __ ] care i'm
gonna take he was probably taking
interviews from his car or truck or
whatever he was in the last couple weeks
like he i think he sat there at the same
[ __ ] point in the road and just kept
taking interviews with newsmax and other
other uh media sources because it
started in the day and by the time it
was like at the end of the day he was
still doing interviews and he was just
there [ __ ] he's like look you're
wrong this is what you know this is what
it is nothing changed this is why
they're doing it calling him out for the
[ __ ] remember this is not jon
stewart's first rodeo he did the same
thing with 9 11 first responders he
fought for nearly a decade or so to get
them the benefits and health care they
needed from the actual
uh harm and health uh issues they
received or actually because
they were there at night they were there
on 9 11. and they were just forgotten
about like oh here's some money this
will be enough for you but people got
cancer health problems long-standing you
know needed assistance needed aid all of
these things and jon stewart was the
only one
who was able to move the needle giving a
very emotionally uh
delivered speech
in front of the committee right right
yeah he actually testified in front of
congress right on on and if it wasn't
for if it wasn't for john stewart i i
can only imagine what have been what it
would have been passed or rejected
without his help and i think the same
thing is happening here
at a much larger scale right it's not
just new york you know and the people
that were first responders it's the
[ __ ] military the veterans
not getting the aid they need
and these republicans they [ __ ] shot
themselves in the foot and continue to
shoot themselves in the foot because
they want to keep pushing this false
fake uh uh lie or this this narrative
this lie about saying how these things
change and the democrats tried to
do a quick one on us and they changed it
here and did this it's like nothing
changed nothing changed and john stewart
is gonna keep [ __ ] blasting off and
saying you guys are [ __ ] idiots
you're liars you're terrible people just
do what you promised to do when you when
you agreed to this in june
and now
and now now i i think it's it is 100
backfiring right and it's backfiring you
know two months away or three months
away from from the midterms
and the longer they push this out the
more and more ammunition the democrats
have to go against the people who are
running for re-election just the
republican party in general that is
what's happened here and instead of just
being like fine you know what okay we'll
just agree to it and kill this they want
to keep fighting and saying oh no no no
we're not going to do it we're not going
to do it biden has to you know binding
is the problem we're doing this out of
spite
it's not i don't think it's going to end
well for them
i don't i don't think it's going to
either
not not only is the pact that's gonna a
packed act going to be passed the way it
is without the toomey amendment i
believe that this is going to damage
republicans in the primary or excuse me
uh in the general in the midterm and um
and again as i said in the beginning 30
minutes this is our chance as america to
give our voice of what we think about
these [ __ ] since january 6. this is
the first national election since then
and today's election day all around the
country speaking of elections
we know that carrie lake is running
for uh giving her
one of carrie lake's best friends and
one of her supporters he's an alpha cuck
he actually he actually helped us coin
the phrase alva yeah live on the shelves
yeah ethan schmidt
he's
he's horrible at trolling by the way he
just says stupid [ __ ] into a camera but
the the thing that really pisses me off
about this [ __ ] idiot more than
anything
is no one really challenges him um to
his face but the other thing too is
carrie like loves this guy
harry lake loves him she loves his
it's little little mustache whatever the
[ __ ] beer is right whatever the [ __ ]
that thing is but here he is trying to
trying to make someone
feel bad about their choice of wearing a
mask again i thought it was like my body
my choice but he's totally he's totally
not that he's a he's uh he's a mask nazi
man he's a mask nazi let's let's watch
why do you got that mask on man
why you got the mask on i'm from
australia
oh you can't wear a mask in the united
states
you can't wear a mask in the united
states what the [ __ ] what does this mean
what the hell this is this is dumber
than dog turds than than [ __ ] lauren
bobert i bet puppy
i bet ethan schmidt's breath
smells like [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
is that why you can't wear a mask i i'll
tell you i'll tell you during during the
vandemic you know when you had to wear a
mask the one the one advantage
disadvantage depending on you know what
time of day or
how long had been since you had you know
uh hygiene in your mouth like a brush
deep brush toothpaste you really did
make you a very aware if you if you yeah
i know you're like just braiding that in
but one it's like if you had bad breath
no one else was really a victim to that
problem anymore if you had a blemish or
something you could cover your face up
no one would even know right if you just
felt like wearing a mask to be you know
just considerate you could do that as
well but i guarantee ethan schmidt here
mr alpha cuck
his breath smells like [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
right you know what you know anyone
around him anyone around him is like oh
dude i need a [ __ ] mask for this guy
i i would i would do this if ethan
schmidt if i was wearing a mess and
ethan schmidt ever come up to me and
asked me why i was wearing a mask i
would pull the mask down and say oh man
i felt really [ __ ] sick i've had a
fever all day and i would just sneeze
the biggest sneeze that i possibly could
muster just sneeze like a [ __ ]
with the mask down because it's like
dude how do you know that this person
wasn't feeling it had a scratchy throat
that morning and they're like you know
what i i took my test right it was
natural
i'm just trying to it doesn't impact
your life
right they're wearing a mask if i if any
it's like why why does that even matter
to the other person right but to alpha
cuck you know ethan schmidt he cares
about what's on your face he's going to
determine that you should have
not you should not have a mask and he's
going to tell you what to do about the
mask on her face you can have a baby you
can't do this and you definitely can't
have you know the vaccine right this guy
is is not free ethan schmidt is a nazi
he is a fascist he is an anti-health
just anti-health that's what he is i
mean wow but he's he's a [ __ ] troll i
mean this goes back to what john stewart
said about jack prosthetic prosthetic
what what did i call him a prostitute i
don't know
proselyte yeah it sounds like it is a
word but i don't know what it is i don't
think it's an actual word i don't know
maybe i made it a word you know but
anyways the point is is that ethan
schmidt is a [ __ ] troll he's the
worst kind because watch what he watch
what he continues to do
after he's done with his trolling
because he never does anything about it
he's always talk it's all [ __ ] talk
he never he never can pony up to
anything i mean you know guys like this
when i was a kid would get their [ __ ]
asses stomped in yeah get their [ __ ]
asses dumped in for doing [ __ ] like this
but let's watch perfect
yeah you can't we can't wear a mask when
you're in my country
oh really yeah you gotta take it off in
his country
why don't you take it off sounds like a
fascist
if you're in my country you can't wear a
mask
but you did talk to a person yeah
you did initiated the conversation you
came up to the guy and said why are you
wearing a mask take off the mask you
can't wear a mask in my country
this [ __ ] dick goes in there thinking
that he's the [ __ ] ruler okay just
let's just let's just be clear about
something here when the fascist or sorry
not when but if the fascists take over
right in this scenario in this world
we're building here if the fascists do
take over ethan schmidt is the first
[ __ ] person to get kicked out
i think they're like this guy's so
[ __ ] annoying
can someone just take him just go deal
with them
right let's let's let's get rid of this
guy like i said when i was a kid when i
was a kid anyone who act like this
anyone who act like when i was get where
i grew up anyone who acted like this
would have his goddamn it would have his
ass dumped in i mean absolutely
absolutely
have his ass kicked every goddamn day
and the only reason why is because he
would bully people and they wouldn't put
up with that kind of [ __ ] right from
someone who's all talk they just
wouldn't but also like this this guy
clearly you know he's there for a gig
he's filming or playing or doing
whatever but like if anyone else in the
street and you went up to someone and
you're like hey why are you wearing that
mask get that mask you can't wear that
mask and you have a [ __ ] phone in
their face
they [ __ ] smack that [ __ ] out and
knock you the [ __ ] out and then that's
how the other if you mess with someone
that's what would happen the last part
the truth i come and approached you to
talk to you about the mask but i don't
talk to people with men
i don't
well no the reason why ethan schmidt
doesn't give his name is because this
guy doesn't know who he is and that's
that's what really pisses ethan schmidt
off is that he doesn't know who he is
because he does all this [ __ ] he does
all this [ __ ] for people who know his
name right [ __ ] that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] but the point is the point is
go vote against someone who supports
this piece of [ __ ] who is carrie lake
carrie lake supports this guy's best
friends they love each other they love
each other he's always talking about
hunting and killing lgbt people
about
killing killing people with men he's
always talking about killing cancer
patients and all kinds of [ __ ] he's a
vile piece of [ __ ] he's a nazi he's a
nincompoop nazi and he's a little [ __ ]
he couldn't back up he couldn't back up
his fascism as soon as the going gets
tough man he's [ __ ] oh [ __ ] well
that's how we that's how we deemed him
the alpha [ __ ] that's where
the kid that the the kid that was uh out
he's a high school kid asking for
signatures yeah and he came up and the
kid [ __ ] owned him right he totally
owned him totally cocked him totally cut
him so ethan you heard it again
more alpha cuck audience
thank you for joining us today i know we
did rapid fire there at the end with the
shitless roundup but it was fun there's
so much video to get to with these
dummies you can't look away you got to
know what is important to go and get
engaged in your democracy today is
election day if you can vote somewhere
go vote and if you can't
try to work hard to engage in the ballot
rather that's registering people to vote
donate to pro-democracy campaigns get
out there knock on doors make phone
calls text message whatever you can to
do to engage in your democracy do it
today
tomorrow we'll be back here noon eastern
11 central nine pacific on youtube
twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
the midas touch facebook page until
tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking